are you pretty like uh careful about
like not like if you're gonna go out to
eat or something not posting or like I
mean even like course leaving the story
at home
oh yeah why when I go anytime I go out
anywhere that's not like down the street
or if like I'm I'm in a public situation
like this is a private situation so yeah
I mean everything you're doing a podcast
what if I go out to eat food like I'm
wearing shorts like dirty shoes and a
hoodie and like nothing no real no
nothing and I'm just like it's
gonna look twice at me because I'm just
like I have nothing for you bro you know
yeah but you could also yeah I was I'm
trying to push this narrative to rappers
and start rocking fake jewelry yeah who
gives a [ __ ] yeah who's gonna request
I've had my share you know if you're a
little baby and you have a fake like
[ __ ] Rolex besides fake watch Buster
he's gonna call you out for sure yeah uh
but who's gonna question you what the
[ __ ] that's what uh
no one can walk up to a little baby with
a diamond testing I'm like [ __ ] off bro
yeah like what he don't even got to say
he got his security he got his people
man yo back up yeah you know do you but
yeah I mean it's not a bad idea when you
first got into the game did you do the
fake jewels of course just because and
it's less about like oh fake jewelry but
more like people kind of give you gift
you this and that right and you find out
like oh he's not giving me real diamonds
he's giving me you know and it's cool
like [ __ ] I'll take it whatever it
happened to me and I was living in Tampa
and shout out to my guy Jane in the
Jeweler he does all Russ's jewelry great
guy but Jane gifted me this giant
[ __ ] chain and I'm thinking I'm
rocking some yo [ __ ] it's happened it's
happened to me for sure that [ __ ] was
plated as [ __ ]
and and the Diamonds were not real but
if it's free it's free and if it looks
good on you [ __ ] it why not and if you
end if you get robbed you're kind of
just like take it yeah no my boy was
like he gave you that and he was like
let me see it he just held it he's like
that's not real nah I was like I don't
know [ __ ] about jewelry yeah